foreign
let's go to all right so we got a
husband a wife
there has been a wife
yes okay so I'm gonna bring them both on
this is scary for me all right let's
take uh we're gonna first we're gonna go
to Faith because you gotta have
Faith the faith the faith what's up
Faith hey Dr John thanks so much for
taking our call of course all right hang
on I'm gonna bring in the mighty p-h-i-l
Phil is that cool
yeah all right Phil you there
I am how's it going are you all in the
same house I'm great are you on the same
house
we are yeah oh this is incredible okay
at some point one of y'all has to say
something really mean about the other
one but you can't do anything because
it's awesome okay so what's up what's up
hey okay so this is gonna take a little
um but I'll just jump off with our
question we are wondering how can we
develop and set healthy boundaries to
protect our marriage and family as we
consider moving in with my dad and my
siblings still at home
okay tell me more
okay so
um a year ago
um actually January of 2021 we got some
devastating news that my mom
um had esophageal cancer we thought
there was hope and
um she went through treatment but
November of 2021 we lost her
um and it was just an awful year
um
so my parents had a DOT they have eight
children four biological I'm the second
oldest and then four adopted
um and of the eight kids there are still
three at home
uh my 18 year old brother a 10 year old
sister an 11 year old brother wow okay
so they're still like yeah I mean your
dad's still he's still full full contact
parenting okay yes 100
um
and my littlest brother has a lot of
um
needs he is paralyzed from the waist
down
um and just very immunocompromised
um she's doing better as he's gotten
older but a lot of physical needs and
emotional trauma and anger and and then
add on the grief of losing your mom
um so then the sister is doing okay but
the 18 year old brother is also
really hurting and exhibiting those
behaviors and then my dad
um it struggles with bipolar disorder
um growing up he really did a great job
of coping with it as a dad and um just
having
handling it well but my mom was his big
support and
um so now she's gone and
during this last year may have been nice
we also we have a little boy and then
we're expecting a baby congratulations
because why because why not y'all should
get a puppy too yeah might as well
um yeah so we we have been the siblings
that have been in a place that's able to
help wanting to help
um what what is that what does that mean
s
you all have stable jobs you've got
income y'all are the only couple that's
married and likes each other like what
is you're able to help what does that
mean okay
um so
uh we
I am stay a stay-at-home mama okay
um Phil and then Phil now working home
his job just transferred so he works
full-time
um in his office but he's home with us
um
and two days a week we have the kids
over here after school
um we so I guess when I say we're the
only ones able my I I have an adult
brother who lives at home but he is also
working full-time and
um seeking to move forward with his own
life and then I have an adult sister
um who's married and has a baby but they
I just very consumed with their own
family and you you're so very very
nicely
very nicely you have said
your other siblings want nothing to do
with this mess
and
you have transposed on yourself as we're
the only ones who are able to as you're
the only ones who will
can we call that is that fair I know you
don't like to talk bad about people I
can tell it in your voice you're the
sweetest person on planet Earth but
that's the truth right
right yes okay there we go there she is
all right so
your brothers your your siblings have
left the building
and it's just you and you're watching
your dad slowly get pulled under water
and you're watching these little kids
slowly have to deal with the their
bipolar dad and the death of their
mother and yeah and the adoption stuff
which is hard on kid all of it all the
same time
and so you and your husband you and Phil
have decided we're going to move in
we're going to move our infant
and our young kids
into this house and we're gonna help
yeah I'm not saying listen none of that
none of that is bad I'm not saying don't
do that I just want to be like really
clear about here's what we're saying
right is going to be the solution to
this okay
and and
definitely more ways that I could
support and he's actually the one that
is a valid a faithful listener to you
and I was like that you need to start
listening and so I did and then I
decided to email and here we go yeah
that's right um all right so what what
is this diary what does looking like
moving in what like moving it what does
that look like Phil I haven't heard from
you you're being
intelligently quiet right now
I I try my best to get me safe
keep you safe so what like what walk me
through what you
are what I've experienced
yeah so
um so about a year ago uh when uh our
mom first uh when she initially passed
away uh the idea had come up about
possibly moving in to just help around
the house and it was immediately shot
down we had zero interest
um at that point who brought it up who
brought it up
um I think Faith might have and then
just other people
um in our life had kind of like
mentioned the idea okay
um but so at the time we just kind of
shot it down our son was
um five six months old at the time
um and it just we just didn't think it'd
be good at the time
um a couple months ago now
um the idea kind of resurfaced we had
some other uh people we look up to in
our lives kind of bring up the idea
again especially kind of after reviewing
the year and kind of hoping you know
things would progress we would start to
move forward as far as her dad's
household is concerned
um and we just continue to see
kind of the same issues
um and things going on most the most
recent of which being
um that the the 18 year old brother who
was still living at home has actually
moved in with us
um and uh just him and dad had a bit of
a falling out and
um the dad actually approached us
um and asked if you know and said hey
you know it's not working at home right
now and we just kind of decided faith
and I to take him in
but so ultimately ultimately yeah so
let's do let's do this let's drill down
how can I best help
sure
so I think I think the biggest thing is
um we we understand faith and I we've
prayed a lot about it and truly feel
God's leading towards it um that that
moving in
um to their house is one of the best
ways we can help and is is what God's
leading us to so with that
um we know that it could be very easy
for attention to arise
um for miscommunications to happen and
so what faith and I are really seeking
to do is figure out
the best um how to clearly communicate
and and what boundaries we need to have
in place to make sure that we're
maintaining our own family because that
has to be our number one priority
um but also to
um helping their family uh in in the
best way that we can
all right excellent all right so I'll
run through these and I'm writing them
down real quick
um
uh and all right so the first and most
important thing here is none of this
works if your marriage falls apart
so Cornerstone number one is you and
faith faith you're there y'all two
getting somewhere no kids except for the
one that you're in the oven now
and deciding what kind of marriage we're
going to have
and I would recommend be real real
specific
we will go on a like obviously about to
have a newborn so that just throws all
this into a blender but
we will go on dates like this this many
times a week
um after we are back to sleeping
together we're gonna have sex this many
times a week and so this is what we're
gonna have to do to make that a reality
we are
um here's how our finances are going to
be separate from this endeavor we're
taking on
here's who's gonna do laundry here's
who's gonna do X and y's see what I'm
saying we are going to be really Crystal
Clear he's going to shop
really crystal clear about uh retirement
our saving for our kids college because
it's real easy for this whole thing to
get real blurred together
and suddenly Phil you're arguing with
her about her dad but suddenly you're
defending this 11 year old which made
her mad and she spent money over here to
buy groceries for everybody and you see
I'm saying you wake up in 10 years and
y'all are
this everything's in Ash see what I'm
saying so the first conversation is
marriage has to go first
the second thing is is you said it great
how are we going to protect our nuclear
family inside of this thing because you
have an infant and you're about to have
a newborn
and infants and newborns need naps and
they need sleep and y'all are going to
be up all night all night and how are we
going to manage this are we going to be
able to hire somebody to come be a
sitter that's going to help out even
though I'm a stay-at-home mom I'm gonna
need some support and some help even
though you're working from home field
you still got to work right how are we
going to manage a overwhelming situation
and taking care of a 70 year old guy
with bipolar disorder and an 18 year old
who's really upset and sadly lost his
mom and a 14 year old and 11 year old
how so how are we going to keep our
nuclear family
how are we going to take care of the
needs of two infants basically is what
I'm saying
um and then we're going to be really
clear about what our goals are meaning
what does help mean
and I think
um you've probably heard me if you ever
listen to the show I used to say it all
the time talking about pictures and
words but my guess is
Faith you have a picture of what help
looks like
and I'm gonna be real reductionistic and
real General General right here okay and
so I'll make it this wrong and I might
mess up the gender roles and all that
I'm just making an example so I'm not
trying to be ugly or anything okay Faith
you may have a picture of help
is this time next year everyone in the
family is sitting around having
Thanksgiving
um you've got this almost one-year-old
in one of those little Papoose pouch
things and you're making dinner because
you're a homemaker and you love it and
your husband comes it out of the study
he's working from home and your bipolar
father who's stable on his meds he high
fives him it's like man you're a great
husband my daughter won the lottery when
she married you like you had this
picture of help
and your husband Phil Phil you might
have a picture of help which is I need
you
father-in-law to get a job and I need
you to not be in the house I need all
the kids to be quiet while I'm at work
because I'm working from home now and
I'm gonna need fill in the blank
and so help is going to look like six
months where we're gonna do this we're
gonna get everybody back on their feet
I'm gonna help Dad get and what we're
gonna have is we're gonna have two
people saying we need to help we need to
help we need help we need help and
you're gonna be saying two completely
different things but that what you by
using that same word
so I want you all to get together in
this Retreat I'm proposing and be very
crystal clear
to The Last Detail what does help mean
what are our goals by moving into this
house what are we going to accomplish by
by coming here
and then as a part of that what can we
actually do
if Dad starts yelling what are we gonna
do
if Dad says I'm not taking my meds
what are we gonna do
if that 18 year old
hit somebody what are we gonna do right
so if we sell our house we're all in I
want to be very clear about planning
some things on the front end
so that we're not surprised and we freak
out and we get surprised and we get
freaked out we make rash decisions along
the way does that make sense
yeah and then we're going to communicate
those very very clearly to Dad
and possibly if he would do it with
dad's counselor so that he's got some
non-parents like he's got some
accountability that doesn't include his
daughter and her and the guy who's
keeps getting his daughter pregnant
right
yeah and I said that on purpose because
there's that c there's that sense in
there right so all that to say is have
saying Hey Dad we aren't you are paying
for your groceries
or you are going to contribute 500 a
month and we will do the shopping you
will do your laundry
or otherwise Faith you're going to
become the pseudo mom to a thousand
people
and try to raise a newborn on two hours
of sleep a night and Phil you are going
to be the breadwinner of a whole bunch
of people in a whole bunch of house and
by working from home down the hall from
a screaming infant an exhausted wife in
a Bonkers 11 year old and a pissed off
18 year old and a dad who won't take his
meds
see what I'm saying see what I'm saying
yeah now I am not in any way saying
don't do this
at all I just want everybody to be clear
yeah okay there is no way that this
isn't very hard
but I don't know anything on Earth it's
not
really that's really good that isn't
also very hard
okay so let's be very crystal clear
about who we're gonna be what our
marriage is going to look like what our
parenting is going to look like what
kind of help we can provide what kind of
help we're willing to provide what are
our boundaries and how are we going to
communicate them
and let's just be really clear about
that and if at any point you say oh this
doesn't work like this in this house
that's a good conversation to have
and I would suggest to anybody that is
encouraging you from outside of your
family's unit outside of you and Phil
outside of you in faith
you know I think it'd be a good idea if
y'all just moved in with your
father-in-law I mean he looks like he
that's real real easy to say if you're
not moving in with your father-in-law on
his three young kids
right
and so it's simple to to lob uh what we
call them uh it's simple to LOB
uh
charity grenades on somebody man you
should give them your car
you should give them your you should
just let them have that other house of
yours well cool thanks that's that's
easy you should just sell your house and
move in
maybe maybe and if you've been
thoughtful about it you've been
obviously
um y'all are very prayerful people and
you've considered that deeply
um man go all in go for it
like my buddy's a Navy SEAL like they
don't look at the at the task log they
don't look at the mission and be like ah
this is too hard no man it's real real
hard that's why you're a Navy SEAL and
we're gonna be very specific about the
challenges that we're gonna face and
we're gonna be very real we're gonna own
reality about what we're going to be
facing and then we're gonna be very very
very specific about how we're going to
overcome each one of those obstacles and
that's what I'm suggesting you do here
y'all are Navy Seals faith and Phil
Navy Seals except you're not you're just
a really incredible daughter
and a otherworldly son-in-law who loves
his father-in-law and he's still
grieving from the loss of mom
and he wants to see those three kids be
well and whole and want to just be great
people so I'm proud it's awesome it's
good to get to talk to you know you
but let's be sober and let's be clear
right about what we're walking into
so that
we can have the identity that we're
going to be people who are well from
people who are whole and we're going to
keep uh this thing the Train on the
tracks here so that
we can quote unquote help